these days it's not enough for your
applications to be
sometimes on they need a database that
maintains high availability while
handling
increasing and seasonal loads in today's
episode of spanner
database unlimited we'll show you under
the hood how cloud spanner provides five
nines that's 99.999 percent
uptime for your mission critical
applications
even at google scale
your customers demand 24 7 access
every second your data is unavailable
you're losing money
you're not able to process orders
customers can't log in
or perhaps your operations are ground to
a halt
regulations such as iso 27001 and hipaa
require availability guarantees
for critical infrastructure like
healthcare or financial services
downtime can have rippling effects into
the economy or public health
so what are typical causes of downtime
for a database
first the infrastructure can fail disks
die
routers melt down or memory is corrupted
spanner like other distributed systems
handles these types of failure by
maintaining
separate copies of your data across
isolated infrastructure
the more copies and isolation the lower
the probability of a complete
failure let's dig into how replication
works in spanner
a regional instance is composed of three
identical
read write replicas when you provision
one spanner node
you actually get three units of storage
and compute that work together
each replica contains a full copy of the
database and is hosted in a different
physical location
or zone the zones are organized to
reduce the chances that more than one
will fail at the same time
for example by having independent power
and cooling
as data changes spanner updates each of
the replicas
it uses the paxos consensus protocol and
truetime to ensure these updates are
strongly consistent
we'll dive into spanner's
industry-leading consistency guarantees
in the next video
if one zone becomes unavailable spanner
automatically routes queries to the
other zones
this all happens online meaning inflate
queries won't fail
and the database can continue to handle
queries and updates
once the zone comes back up it will
catch up from the other replicas
automatically and resume handling
traffic once it's current
no manual intervention is needed and
there's never any downtime
regional spanner configurations support
up to four nines or 99.99
availability for mission critical
applications
while very unlikely a region can be a
single point of failure
for example in a natural disaster
so spanner also offers multi-region
configurations
in this case it spreads data over
geographically dispersed locations using
google's
dedicated network by spreading replicas
over multiple
independent regions a multi-region
configuration can achieve up to five
nines of availability for the most
demanding uptime requirements such as in
financial services
online gaming and retail this is the
level of availability you need
spanner does a lot of work behind the
scenes to ensure availability
consistency and performance at scale
google's own applications depend on it
today
however to your developers it looks like
a single scale up database
they don't have to worry about brittle
sharding eventual consistency or manual
failover
and can focus on innovation
another source of potential downtime is
regular maintenance
software gets updated firmware is
patched security policies are revised
which in most cases means bringing down
the database
in a world of always-on access and
increasing interdependence of business
processes
finding maintenance windows across an
application set can be impossible
with spanner though plan database
maintenance is a thing of the past
spanner is fully managed google's
best-in-class site reliability
engineering ensures it's always
up to date without having to bring down
the database
a third source of potential downtime is
changes in applications that rely on the
database
if your application requires a schema
change like adding a new table
or changing a data type spanner's unique
schema versioning allows you to apply
changes to a live
instance without missing a beat some
schema updates are applied immediately
such as adding a not
null column others require validation to
avoid violating consistency constraints
or require backfilling such as adding an
index
while this backfilling happens
automatically in the background
spanner continues to service queries
against the previous version of the
schema
once the changes are completed it
automatically switches over to the new
schema providing a 100 consistent view
of the data
without incurring any downtime another
application change that can cause
downtime
bugs for example a delete that leaves
off a where condition and deletes too
much data
or a calculation error that corrupts
data
but spanner provides transactionally
consistent backups
allowing you to roll back to a known
good state
this is possible because every update
and spanner happens at a time stamp
instead of changing the data in place
spanner marks the old data as expired
and new data is available
at this time using this precise change
tracking backups always capture a
consistent snapshot of the data
even as data is updated during the time
it takes for the backup to complete
restoring a consistent view of the data
from a backup is simple and can be
online in minutes
reducing the recovery time objective
during a disaster
today we showed you how spanner provides
availability at scale
in the next episode we're diving into
spanner's consistency at scale
if you thought you could only have two
of the three well
stay tuned for next episode's conclusion
thanks for joining us today on spanner
database
unlimited
you